[Music]
hey i have to mention uh how proud we
are of you because i don't know how many
people know this probably none of you
mindy started out in show business as
our intern
[Applause]
i fantastic 19 i was a sophomore in
college
tonight this is how this is a number of
years ago back when we were doing the
show in new york 14 years ago and i yeah
i took the train down from college and
came to it was so glamorous it was
awesome i don't think i don't think of
our show as ever being glamorous but no
i mean doctor this isn't like funny but
you are my comedy hero i couldn't
believe how starstruck i was working
there it's so cool like my dream was
like one day could i ever be like a
guest on conan that seemed too crazy to
think about but yeah no and um
but i also i was i was the worst intern
that's ever worked on the program yeah
yeah you've mentioned this before you've
mentioned that you were a terrible
intern what were you about what were you
doing that was did you take stuff did
you
did you smash things well i came i
wanted to work there not to learn how to
photocopy things but to like watch you
and when you're an intern here like
it's like watch me doing what
just see you and
you're because you're such a genius so
that's why i'm sorry anyway i took that
to so i wouldn't do my things that i was
hired to do i would just kind of like
follow you around
i remember that part
i remember thinking she's an amazing
intern she's hiding the ceiling
yeah break it down you're like a ninja
like a creep yeah so oh this is what you
learned from watching this segment is
what a creep buy it
for so many years tune in
tune in to the mindy project